Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. You
can call the voicemail number anytime you
want.
And here is a really good question about all
of these so-called voter integrity measures
that Republicans have been and want to continue
passing.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: A day that these voter suppression
tactics kind of hard to find statistical analysis
on their facts.
Could you could you share what percentage,
what percentage of the estimate of these these
tactics prevent illegal voting or versions
of that?
And what percentage of voters who want to
vote yea are unable to vote because they've
been purged from the voter rolls or other
suppression tactic where they.
They said they were unable to vote.
I'm just assuming that they estimate that
based on polls or something else.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So this this is a good question, which is
all this stuff Republicans do, legally speaking,
in order to prevent illegal voting.
How much illegal voting does it actually prevent
versus how many legal voters end up being
disenfranchized, which is really the design
of it?
There is absolutely no evidence whatsoever
that in-person voter fraud is a materially
significant issue.
Now, it's important to say materially significant
because Republicans will hear that and they'll
write in and they'll say, what about Jim Bob
who voted twice?
Or what about Bobby Sue, who figured out how
to vote under her cousin's name or whatever?
The question is, you know, in a country of
three hundred and thirty one million people,
there are examples of everything.
Is there any evidence that all of these in-person
types of voter fraud are materially significant
to election results?
And the answer is no.
On the other hand, we know of tons of people
who were purged from voter rolls for so-called
inactivity, who were denied the ability to
vote because of other clerical issues that
were caused by these guidelines and restrictions
put in place by Republicans.
There are people who opted just not to even
go and vote because Republicans disproportionately
shut down voting booths and curtail voting
hours and disproportionately Democratic areas.
So the the Brennan Center for Justice has
a lot of great data on this.
And the most important takeaway is the voter
suppression tactics from Republicans, because
that's what they are, which they claim to
be in the spirit of preventing illegal votes.
They do way more to interfere with people
legally voting than they do to curb what is
almost insignificant, almost nonexistent and
statistically insignificant in-person voter
fraud.
The real way that you affect elections is
by suppressing the vote at the big picture
level.
You don't flip an election by going with your
friends to multiple polling places and claiming
to be different people.
You don't go and round up the people who are
jurors and say, even though your dad's senior
is dead.
Go and vote for yourself and for your dad.
No, that's not how you steal an election just
doesn't happen.
And the question is well asked and really
gets to the heart of that.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Teenagers are helping each other get covid
shots when their parents are anti vax.
Fascinating that this is what's going on.
The defiant action of teenagers is to get
themselves vaccinated even when their parents
don't want them to.
Unbelievable trials to suck carbon dioxide
from the air are going to start across the
United Kingdom.
And the Texas Senate has approved a bill limiting
how race and racism can be taught in public
school classrooms.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
I would love it if you joined us on the bonus
Pat will be joining me.
Why don't you join me as well?
You can get instant access by signing up at
join